avec un sujet de santé des plus tabou ce
qui vous a beaucoup fait réagir et je
pense qu'il va faire réagir nos
téléspectateurs s'agit des erreurs
médicales
si aujourd'hui il n'existe pas de
chiffres officiels elles seraient plus
répandue colonne pense et peuvent très
souvent avoir des conséquences
désastreuses pour les patients un sujet
de je t'aime et c'est un diagnostic mal
posé une erreur de dosage une infection
nosocomiale ses erreurs médicales dans
le milieu hospitalier on les appelle des
ei les événements indésirables graves
alors qu'aujourd'hui un médecin pour ça
sur deux étant burnout que 77% des
praticiens constate une dégradation de
la qualité des soins
l'association des deux victimes le lien
fait état de 60 mille décès par an en
france suite à des erreurs médicales
les erreurs médicales ça concerne tout
le monde encore faut-il que les langues
se délient en france l'omerta règne
mais comment lutter contre les erreurs
médicales si on ne les sanctionne pas
sur le site communautaire hospitalité on
note et on dénonce plus jamais une
expérience horrible fuyez abominable
alors qu'est ce qu'on pense de ceux de
ce sujet les erreurs médicales avec un
chiffre assez dingue que j'ai relevé
soixante mille personnes perdraient la
vie chaque année en france à la suite
d'un accident médical
jean-michel qu'est ce que vous pensez
que je ne crois pas du tout ça arrive
les erreurs médicales puisque les
médecins ils ont une obligation de
moyens et pas forcément une obligation
de résultat ils peuvent être fatigué
comme c'est dit aux urgences il peut y
avoir une erreur dans l'incompétence est
ce ta je crois pas du tout qui est
soixante mille décès par l'alors
méditerranée moi vous dites ils peuvent
être fatigué s'il ya bien un métier où
ils n'ont pas le droit d'être fatigué
ils ont entre leurs mains la vie d'un
patient pas excusez moi vous pouvez pas
prévoir ce qui se passe dans une nuit de
garde
ça veut dire qu il est 11 heures du soir
tout est calme d'un seul coup il va y
avoir un terrible accident de voiture
tout le monde est débordé il va y avoir
30 personnes en même temps dans la salle
d'attenté
comment faire quand y'a deux médecins
quatre infirmières cela veut dire qu ils
font un ordre de priorité mais ensuite
dans l'ordre de priorité de temps en
temps ça va tellement vite qu'ils sont
obligés de régler le problème
donc je n'excuse pas c'est vrai que ça
devrait pas se produire et c'est pour ça
que les nouvelles technologies j'y crois
beaucoup à la possibilité d'examiner
quelqu'un avec des scanners automatisé
et c'est en 2016 et 1 4575 demande
déposée à l'oniam
l'oniam c'est l'office national
d'indemnisation des accidents médicaux
et 35% ont entraîné une indemnisation
j'allais dire seulement 35%
donc est ce qu'il n'ya pas aussi les
médecins qui se couvrent entre eux en
disant dans ce cas là non non c'était
normal ben voilà on a perdu le dossier
médical de la personne ou non mais un
peu sous le tapis mais bien sûr que oui
c'est pas belle et terrible et ressentir
ici c'était bien sûr que oui à une
espèce de solidarité corporatiste
à un moment donné on n'a pas envie de
faire mal à quelqu'un mais quand
l'erreur est vraiment une erreur d'
incompétence ou une erreur de négligence
là y'a pas un médecin qui couvre un
autre médecin d'accord et quand il ya
une erreur on comprend le contexte je
suis désolé de vous dire ça c'est pas un
peu jean-michel peut-être que tu
n'excuse pas mais en tout cas tu résumes
à toi tout seul ce qu'on a vu dans le
reportage c'est à dire qu'il ya une
omerta
il n'y a pas de sanction parce qu'il ya
une chape de tolérance et d'indulgence
on sait pas pourquoi
sur la tête des médecins qui pourraient
faire des erreurs médicales
mais finalement ce serait pas très grave
ce serait en tout cas beaucoup moins
grave qu'une erreur judiciaire etc
c'est pas possible de laisser passer ça
et de juste constaté de mettre à ce soit
puisque sa demande ou livre d'entretiens
10 40 ans a dépendu des la gironde à mai
mois mais dans le sujet il y avait
notamment par exemple ce jeune homme qui
est venu parce qu'il avait une fracture
du tibia on lui a ensuite la jambe genre
le préjudice était là il ya très très
fort pratique mais des fois le patient
est responsable je vous raconte une
histoire
on était dans un service de médecine le
patient est un diplomate très important
il insiste pour que la fonction soit
faite par le chef de service
le chef de service il tient à peine sur
ses deux jambes il insiste tellement
qu'on lui fait faire le gars il
ponctionne un poumon est en fait c'est
l'autre qu'il fallait ponctionner et
nous tous on peut rien dire parce qu'à
ce moment là le gars insistait pour que
ce soit le chef de service le chef de
service elf et on est traumatisée et
vite vite vite l'agrégé de services
rectifier les choses
le problème serge michels et que vous
nous sortez les cas extrêmes comme
l'accident de voiture etc
moi j'ai eu sous mes yeux un ami
footballeur qui avait une opération des
croisés du genou gauche a fait refaire
s'est réveillé on lui a dit tout s'est
bien passé il a regardé c'était son
genou droit qui était ben non c est donc
c'était un petit peu son bien et son
métier quand même footballeur à un
niveau de troisième division mais quand
même
et du coup ces choses-là n'y a pas
d'excusés a personne qui est le meilleur
c'est le cas nous dire que nous ferons
bien c'est que vous dites il ya deux
types d'erreurs entre guillemets willy à
l'erreur parce que le type est
incompétent sous des noms je ne sais
quoi ou négligés ou pas et là c'est une
erreur qui soit qu'il faudrait
réprimandé il ya une erreur qui est lié
à la structure même des hôpitaux etc où
ils sont sous effectif et ils sont
débordés et puis vous vous dites c'est
pas les mêmes erreurs ensuite ça dépend
du type de préjudice et troisièmement il
ya des demandes qui sont complètement
farfelus aussi ça veut dire on peut pas
considérer que c'est une erreur médicale
quand quelqu'un ce sera ton prise sur
une posologie de médicaments ça c'est eu
d'effet non mais s'il n'y a pas d'effets
négatifs c'est un fait mais c'est
surtout que ça va bien aller
est-ce que tu peux au moins m'accorder
ça tant qu'on ne sanctionnera pas comme
on le fait dans d'autres pays
ça ne ça ne va qu'empirer il ya un
médecin sur deux aujourd'hui et on le
dit dans le reportage qui en burn out
ils ne sont pas suffisamment bonnes
raisons sans les hommes aiment cet outil
mis au fait qu'ils n'ont pas ce que
laissait entendre une excuse médecin est
en train de donner une excuse me
sanctionneraient pas à un moment donné
plus les héros du le gac et que écoulé
et qui aurait un les sélectionnés rooney
est complètement in et vous comprendrez
l'avait caroline parce que c'est un peu
le sentiment général on entend très
souvent les gens dire aux de toute façon
c'est l'heure des médecins qui décident
oui ou non et comme ils se couvrent
entre eux ça passivement à la médecin
qui décidera lasser les tribunaux mais
en l'occurrence le gars qui ampute une
jambonneau au lieu du mode jambes quoi
qu'il fasse c'est un incompétent c'est
une faute médicale lourde ça mais c'est
pour ça que je te dis ne donne pas une
excuse ne dis pas que c'est le burn out
même quand tu es fatigué tu connais à
droite de sa gauche quand même faut pas
délirer
cl c'est une compétence ericsson se
déjuge pas entre eux et un truc génial
qui arrivent et qui va avancer avec le
temps moi c'est les sites internet de
notation ou devoir se dire sur ou où ça
va où ça va vous voulez qu'on fasse une
sorte de ligue 1
et si la gueule du médecin ne revient
pas tu vas mal le noter et ujpa sur sa
compétence du juge en général un médecin
sur l'accueil tu le juge jamais sur la
compétence c'est ça le problème
eh bien on va on a posé la question de
téléspectateurs les erreurs dans les
hôpitaux c'est inadmissible ou bien vous
comprenez ça peut arriver
inadmissible pour 70% d'entre vous ça
peut arriver pour 30% n'hésitez pas à
réagir
et nous dire ce que vous pensez de ça
parce que l'effective mans ça peut être
parfois absolument dramatique